el pasado viernes 31 de agosto rodaba
las redes sociales un aviso publicitario
que había aquí en todo un en toronto
donde una compañía de venta de café
asociaba a pablo escobar con el producto
número uno exportación de colombia
y al final del chiste pues el productor
del café es la persona que obviamente
mostró su molestia es de origen uruguayo
publicó esta imagen en un grupo que es
de nuestro vecindario
esta persona y yo tuvimos que empezar
una conversación de porque esto era
negativo de porque esto era irrespetuoso
para los millones de colombianos y
colombianas que no solo hemos estado en
contra de la violencia o en contra de la
imagen negativa que se ha creado
colombia en relación a dar le
tranquilizaba tantísima publicidad y
visibilidad pablo escobar sino que
teníamos que lidiar tuvimos que lidiar
también con que se nos dijera que éramos
amargados que muy fáciles de ofender
etcétera etcétera el punto es que
decidimos yo yo decidí conectarme con el
establecimiento dejarle saber que esto
era ofensivo dejarles saber que la
situación era mucho más complicada y que
no no ameritaba que fuese un chiste que
les diera ellos publicidad sobre todo
porque desconocía la historia de muchos
de nosotros y sobre todo la historia de
muchos de nosotros que tenemos que vivir
día
día a día con el estereotipo de
relacionar a los colombianos con las
drogas la respuesta que recibí por
supuesto fue
menos alentadora no solo porque el dueño
del establecimiento o la persona que
hace la gerencia no reconocía que su
acción era ofensiva sino que además de
decir que él tenía derecho de libertad
de expresión o que los colombianos no
éramos los únicos que sufrían que los
musulmanes los negros los judíos todos
han tenido de historias que son
lamentables pero pues que al final del
día no son culpa de él y que puede hacer
los chistes que él quiera
esa respuesta fue mucho más dolorosa yo
diría corrigieron la acción fue quitando
el aviso dejándolo saber que quitar el
aviso pero la razón por la que lo
quitaban era porque las personas nos
ofendemos muy fácilmente estas fueron
sus palabras esta conversación ocurre
vía email con esta persona tengo
entendido que quitaron su aviso pero no
por las razones que que son de fondo
sino que las quitaron para no tener que
lidiar con la gente que está ofendida lo
cual resulta como te digo bastante
problemático
pero esto me lleva una reflexión mucho
más grande y es el hecho de que teníamos
que estar defendiendo nos y digo
teníamos porque como digo un hombre de
origen uruguayo fue que empezó la
conversación diciendo que le parecía
ofensivo y yo me uní a esa conversación
como colombiana y dejando saber también
el sentimiento de respeto y frustración
pero toda la campaña de defensa que nos
tocó hacer a nuestros propios
sentimientos a nuestra propia existencia
porque para las personas que estaban en
esa conversación o estamos siendo
bastante dramáticos o eso era un simple
chiste o no éramos muy amargados o no
entendíamos lo que era sufrir porque por
qué
para ellos no había nada más
nosotros terminamos pensando oh yo
termino pensando que este es el uso del
privilegio que es el uso de no saber de
no saber y no reconocer la existencia
del otro y las realidades del otro la
realidad es que no son iguales a las
nuestras y que por tanto no nos permiten
cuestionar la existencia de esas otras
personas